let's talk about Ai and machine learning
for a little bit so we're essentially
going to be using AI to create a Mr B
Style YouTube video artificial
intelligence could become a complete
disaster for YouTube I'm going to try to
start a YouTube channel using only ai ai
has no soul but it also might provide
some unique benefits the future is here
content Creation in general is going to
change dramatically over the next few
years but there is one thing that's
going to follow this conversational AI
thing everywhere it goes well artificial
intelligence Destroy YouTube
[Music]
let's begin by going over the biggest
problems before explaining exactly how
this will impact YouTube and the
millions of creators who upload videos
to the platform this all started when a
tick talker named Ghostwriter 977
uploaded an AI generated song featuring
Drake and The Weeknd people had been
using AI to create covers and mashups of
popular songs for months but this was
the first time a new song really sounded
like it could have been made by a famous
artist part on my sleeve marked a
turning point play it for any casual
Drake fan and they would never know it
was made by Ai and that has some massive
implications everyone immediately jumped
to the most extreme conclusion will this
destroy the music industry as we know it
see the situation isn't actually all
that dangerous for big creators like
Drake in fact he might wind up
benefiting the most from these new AI
Technologies let's start by analyzing
the song hard on my sleeve because a lot
of people don't really understand what's
going on here
[Music]
that's why
don't get me wrong the song sounds great
but while the media is reporting that it
was entirely generated by artificial
intelligence there's a lot more to it
than that first the beat was created by
a human using industry standard software
they picked out the instrumentals and
laid down the notes that they thought
sounded appropriate then the lyrics were
likely written at least in part by a
human cha gbt is getting really good at
writing lyrics but it still needs a lot
of guidance in order to hit specific
topics it's not enough to just ask
Chachi BT to write a banger Drake verse
the result will be far too generic
integrating those specific mentions of
Selena Gomez and Justin Bieber was
probably the idea of Ghostwriter 977
after all he claims to be a ghost writer
this is his job but what about the Drake
voice that's what made the song really
unbelievable after all well the voice
wasn't actually entirely generated by AI
there are Services working on being able
to generate voices just from text input
but this song used a different method
called style transfer it's more like a
deep fake than a mid-journey style image
generation I am not Morgan Freeman and
what you see is not real
someone who can probably do a pretty
good Drake impression recorded the
lyrics and then used AI to transfer the
style of Drake's voice onto their
recording when you're making a deep fake
it helps to have someone who at least
has the same face shape as the person
you're faking so when Corridor crew
wanted to create convincing deep fakes
of Tom Cruise and Tupac they hired
look-alikes to serve as the underlying
reference footage and audio deep fakes
work the same way better inputs yield
better outputs but that's almost beside
the point even though it still clearly
took a lot of human effort to make this
song it was way cheaper than paying
Drake to record the verse if anyone can
make a Drake song in their bedroom with
just a few hours of work clearly the
music industry is going to change
dramatically right well yes and no
we've actually been here before back in
1999 the MP3 format allowed people to
share music with each other and Napster
used the internet to push that to
maximum scale the entire music industry
had been designed around selling CDs and
the shift away from these physical disks
basically destroyed the core business
model of the music industry at the time
the Napster era was exciting if you are
a broke kid who just wanted to listen to
free music it's free and it's easy and
you know it's wrong yeah but a lot of
people do it pretty much everybody does
but everyone in the music industry knew
that it would be hugely disruptive in
the long term business model built on
infringement is not only morally wrong
but legally wrong if artists could no
longer make money selling music they'd
stop making music entirely if no one was
paying for music artists simply couldn't
afford to buy instruments rent Studios
hire producers or do any of the other
important things required to make great
music fortunately a solution emerged
pretty quickly instead of fighting the
internet in MP3 distribution the music
industry embraced it Sean Fanning failed
to find a legitimate business model with
Napster and the courts shut down the
network in 2001 but Sean Fanning had
started the company with another Sean
Sean Parker yes that Sean Parker the
former president of Facebook who was
famously played by Justin Timberlake in
The Social Network in 2006 Sean Parker
became a managing partner at Founders
fund The Venture Capital firm that
backed Facebook early on and while he
was there he started looking for a
company that could make the original
Vision that Napster had pioneered a
reality but but they would need to do it
legally this time around a few years
later a friend showed him Spotify and he
invested 15 million dollars in the
company Spotify had figured out that
what consumers really wanted was access
to every song at any time but they were
willing to pay for that the plan worked
and the music industry was able to hit a
new all-time high for Revenue in 2021.
CD sales had been shrinking ever since
Napster came on the scene in 1999 and
the music industry had suffered through
a rough 15-year period of declining
sales but by finally leaning into the
internet instead of fighting it they
were able to restore growth the shift
from CD sales to streaming did change
the nature of music production in some
significant ways though now artists
weren't limited to what would fit on a
single CD so albums could be any length
with an unlimited catalog stored on the
internet there was no downside to
releasing more music so artists started
producing more and more songs the
internet also removed traditional
Gatekeepers instead of needing to get a
record label to manufacture physical CDs
for you and then distribute them into
doors songs were instantly available
everywhere so new artists could go viral
with a single song faster than ever
before so what does all this mean for
YouTube
when the founders of YouTube first
launched the site in 2005 they ran into
many of the same problems as Napster
there was a ton of copyright
infringement in the early days of
YouTube people would upload songs movies
and TV shows anything that could get
them views and earn them ad Revenue it
was pretty chaotic but they ultimately
solved the problem by creating the
content ID system in the early days
record labels would have to search
YouTube for illegally uploaded songs and
then submit requests to YouTube to get
the offending videos taken down Content
ID solved this by scanning every Youtube
upload and cross-referencing new videos
against copyrighted material now if you
upload a video featuring a Drake song
YouTube doesn't even need to take that
video down they can just divert the ad
Revenue to Drake's record label and
everyone's happy and this is clearly the
future of AI generated content Drake
owns his name image and likeness it
doesn't actually matter that he didn't
record hard on my sleeve he'll be able
to get paid for it this will still mean
a big change for the way the music
industry works and how artists get paid
right now Drake's record label is
fighting to remove every copy of heart
on my sleeve from the internet you can't
stream it on Spotify anymore and uploads
are constantly being taken down from
YouTube but we're far from the end of
the road here it's important to remember
that most major artists work with large
teams Drake himself admitted in an
interview with Vader that he works with
a group of writers to help develop his
lyrics but it doesn't really matter
since the value of a Drake song comes
from the fact that it's Drake song and
not some unrecognizable artist even
though the record labels are scrambling
to ban AI generated content in the short
term this is probably going to play out
just like it did 20 years ago eventually
the music industry will learn to lean
into Ai and figure out a way to continue
to make money while giving people what
they want so what could that look like
well the simplest solution would be
something like what YouTube has already
built with content ID if the platforms
detect a song using Drake's voice that
song is ineligible for monetization and
all ad Revenue flows directly to Drake's
label big platforms like YouTube and
Spotify are also in a unique position to
authenticate what's real and what's fake
real artists already have verified
accounts on that so if you want to make
sure you're listening to a real Drake
song you better be sure that you're on
his page and in the longer term it's
clear that artists will Embrace working
with AI instead of against it small
Independent Producers have been
uploading type beats to YouTube for
years these tracks often mimic the style
of a particular rapper and sometimes
they even get used by the actual rapper
they are mimicking earlier this year J
Cole searched for J Cole Type Beat on
YouTube and found something that he
liked ultimately it was good enough to
be a real song so he recorded vocals and
let the producer upload the final track
to his channel something similar could
happen with AI generated vocals if Drake
winds up liking a particularly viral AI
song he could record an official version
and even perform it live big artists
like Drake are going to be massive
winners in the AI Revolution they own
their intellectual property and it won't
matter if someone else prompted AI to
create a song with their voice they are
still going to reap the financial
rewards but what about smaller creators
the average YouTuber someone who doesn't
have international Fame like Drake well
this is where things get really
interesting
[Music]
it's easy to look at the crazy news
about Ai and assume that all video will
soon be entirely synthetic and it makes
sense in theory right chat GPT can write
a script mid-journey can generate
visuals and plenty of services can
synthesize voiceovers put those together
and you have all the ingredients to make
a YouTube video automatically but we
aren't quite there yet every piece of AI
generated content still requires a lot
of human effort to produce high quality
results AI is clearly advancing quickly
but people are starting to get a little
crazy with their predictions in order
order to predict how things will unfold
here it's critical to understand what I
call the Centaur era just like the half
man half-horse creature from Greek
mythology the near-term future of
content creation will involve humans
working in close coordination with AI to
push production to new heights this
Centaur concept first showed up during
chess competitions in the 1990s Gary
Kasparov was the world chess champion at
the time and he thought that no computer
could ever defeat him computers were
still so simple back then they didn't
really seem capable of advanced
reasoning but then in 1997 IBM's deep
blue beat him in a public match it was a
huge turning point in the development of
artificial intelligence and deep blue
didn't even use any modern AI methods
but after that match ended and deep blue
had been crowned chess champion a new
Challenger emerged instead of just a
single human playing a single computer a
human would now play alongside a
computer and work together as a centaur
this combination of human and machine
wound up being incredibly effective the
computer could act as a check on every
move to prevent unnecessary blunders
while the human could read the opponent
and focus on long-term strategy for
years these mixed AI human Centaur teams
were able to outperform Pure AI programs
at chess and this is the era that we're
entering now with content production
increasingly YouTube creators who are
able to work alongside tools like Chachi
PT and mid-journey will be able to
produce better videos faster and more
efficiently we see Sparks of this
already with videos like the Harry
Potter Balenciaga mashup it's not
impossible to create a video like that
without AI a team of Pixar level artists
working for a few weeks could probably
recreate it without any AI tools but it
would be extremely expensive to do so
mid Journey was able to give the creator
of Harry Potter Balenciaga the ability
to bring this bizarre and hilarious
concept to life basically for free it
still required a lot of human work to
combine find the different AI generated
elements and most importantly come up
with the idea the video works so well
because combining characters from a
beloved children's book with a
pretentious High fashion brand is so
non-sequitur the originality and
unconventional thinking that went into
deciding to make this viral video is
something that humans will be better
than AI at for a very long time but at
the same time that Advantage may not
last forever after all Centaur teams
don't stand a chance of winning a chess
anymore if artificial intelligence
continues to compound exponentially it's
hard to imagine a particular skill set
that will remain untouched we don't know
how long it will take to create super
intelligent AGI it could be years or it
could be decades so instead of jumping
too far into the future it's more useful
to work through the various parts of
YouTube that will be affected by AI
first we know that YouTube content
creation is entering a centaur era so
how will this change the platform
the most basic videos will get automated
by AI simple videos that are just
adaptations of Wikipedia articles or
listicles of Reddit comments those will
be replaced by AI generated content but
for more ambitious YouTubers AI will
very much be a co-pilot Microsoft
partnered with openai for this very
reason they recognize that AI is best
used as a co-pilot right now so they are
integrating it into Microsoft Office to
help people write more efficiently and
that co-pilot branding which was first
used in their GitHub code generation
tool speaks to the importance of the
Centaur model AI co-pilots allow humans
to act as centaurs and produce better
results faster and this works on the
visual side of things as well generative
imagery has already helped me a ton when
openai released Dolly I produced a video
telling the history of artificial
intelligence and Illustrated the entire
video using only AI generated images the
technology has gotten a lot better
recently and is starting to replace
stock footage and some of my videos it
still requires human input to know what
images look good and fit the story just
like searching through a stock footage
library but the possibilities are
endless many YouTubers like to say that
gear doesn't matter when they get asked
about starting a YouTube channel it
doesn't matter to me just just make
something put something into the world
this is good advice for new creators
instead of worrying about buying the
perfect camera it's usually best to just
get started and then improve your
equipment over time AI is going to make
gear even less of an issue going forward
not only does every modern smartphone
already have a ton of AI features
integrated into the camera system to
produce better output but there are also
a ton of new AI tools to restore the
quality of low-res video add slow motion
after the fact and even clean up noisy
audio the cost of creating a YouTube
video is going to drop lower and lower
until basically anyone can create any
video they want just by typing a few
prompts so in that world who wins what
will the top YouTubers look like
there are basically two paths forward as
I see it and to understand them we need
to talk about Jake Tran and James Janney
these these new guys are Youtubers with
over a million subscribers they both
make video essays about business and
they focus on cinematic storytelling but
they run their businesses completely
differently Jake is all about scale
while James is all about quality even
though they both have nearly the exact
same number of subscribers Jake uploads
nearly every single day while James
Spends months working on a single video
the end result is that even though James
Janney gets 10 times the amount of views
per video on average Jake Tran still
gets four times as many views per month
the quantity at all cost strategy has
allowed Jake to get lots of views but in
the process most of his audience turned
on him and he drew some negative
attention from coffeezilla James Janney
on the other hand is loved by his
community they patiently wait for the
next upload and show up in droves when
it goes live if making YouTube videos is
just about paying the bills either
strategy can work Jake Tran is at the
extreme of optimization he outsources
everything and at one point he even
hired other narrators to do the
voiceover so that he wouldn't have to
spend any time on that AI will push this
even further there will clearly be
channels that Outsource nearly
everything to AI systems but on the
other end of the spectrum I think there
will still be a place for the James
jannies of the world so let's talk about
the things where AI falls short
[Music]
EBT is only going to get better at
summarizing information repurposing
existing articles and generally
delivering the right answers this means
that humans will need to focus on
finding truly original ideas thinking
unconventionally and asking the right
question so any YouTuber who can
consistently provide a unique Viewpoint
that isn't just a summary of what's
already been written about a topic will
remain relevant another area where
humans will have the edge over AI for a
long time will be in surfacing
information that doesn't exist on the
internet coffeezilla has basically
become an investigative journalist at
this point when he reports on a fraud he
isn't just paraphrasing a CNBC article
about the topic he's actually going out
and talking to real people and finding
new facts to help tell the story this is
going to be extremely valuable for a
very very long time and it doesn't stop
there the most successful YouTubers
today are able to establish a connection
with their audiences and it's going to
be really hard for AI to replace that
take live streamers like Ludwig for
instance distance not only will it be
years before AI video generation gets to
the point where it can be used on live
streams but Ludwig's audience likes the
fact that he's a real person and seems
like a relatable guy AI models still
require months to train and it's a big
challenge to keep them up to date with
the latest information so recreating
something like a Ludwig live stream
where he's reacting to the latest news
and what his viewers are saying in chat
will be a big challenge even still it
won't be impossible and it's probably
only a matter of time so what then
what happens when there are AI channels
that are truly indistinguishable from
the YouTubers we know today well I think
it's useful to return to the history of
chess for hundreds of years humans were
dominant at chess then we got beat by AI
in 1997 and entered the Centaur era for
about 20 years human AI centaurs were
the best at chess and then AI took over
completely it's simply impossible for a
human to win at chess against an AI
system no matter what tools they have at
their disposal but here's the
interesting thing he human chess has
never been more popular
chess.com has over a hundred million
users Hikaru Nakamura and Magnus Carlson
have massive followings on Twitch and
Netflix even produced a hit show all
about Chess for some reason we humans
don't just want to see the best possible
game of chess get played out between two
AIS we want to see humans battle it out
it might just be an innate bias against
computers but I think this will stick
around for a long time fundamentally
every YouTuber is going to reach a fork
in the road they'll have two options two
opportunities really they can either use
AI to optimize their production for
maximum quantity pumping out as many
low-cost videos as possible in order to
gain a lot of views or they can focus on
quality let AI help them with what it
does Best But still focus on injecting
that human element that makes their
videos special to their core audience
the risk of going the mass production
route is that it can be a bit of a race
to the bottom eventually these videos
might be automatically produced by
YouTube directly since they have all the
training data on the other hand if you
focus on what's hardest for AI to
replicate UniQue Ideas personal stories
investigative reporting that will
probably be a much longer and more
defensible Road this AI stuff is moving
incredibly quickly right now but if you
zoom out this has actually been in the
works for decades so if you want to
understand the history of artificial
intelligence just go watch this video
next thanks a lot